PROFESSOR: The well
ordering principle
is one of those
facts in mathematics
that's so obvious that
you hardly notice it.
And the objective of
this brief introduction
is to call your attention to it.
We've actually used it already.
And in subsequent segments
of this presentation,
I'll show lots of
applications of it.
So here's a statement of
the well ordering principle.
Every nonempty set of
nonnegative integers
has a least element.
Now this is probably familiar.
Maybe you haven't
even thought about it.
But now that I mentioned it,
I expect it's a familiar idea.
And it's pretty
obvious too if you
think about it for a minute.
Here's a way to think about it.
Given an nonempty set of
integers, you could ask,
is 0 the least element in it?
Well, if it is,
then you're done.
Then you could say, is 1
the least element in it?
And if it is, you're done.
And if it isn't, you could
say 2, is 2 the least element?
And so on.
Given that it's not
empty, eventually you're
to hit the least element.
So, if it wasn't
obvious before, there
is something of a
hand-waving proof of it.
But I want to get you
to think about this well
ordering principle a little bit
because it's not-- there are
some technical parts
of it that matter.
So for example, suppose I
replace nonnegative integers
by nonnegative rationals.
And I asked does every nonempty
set of nonnegative rationals
have a least element?
Well, there is a least
nonnegative rational, namely 0.
But not every nonnegative set of
rationals has a least element.
I'll let you think
of an example.
Another variant is
when, instead of talking
about the nonnegative
integers, I just
talk about all the integers.
Is there a least integer?
Well, no, obviously because
minus 1 is not the least.
And minus 2 is not the least.
And there isn't
any least integer.
We take for granted the
well ordering principle just
all the time.
If I ask you, what was the
youngest age of an MIT graduate
well, you wouldn't for a
moment wonder whether there
was a youngest age.
And if I asked you for the
smallest number of neurons
in any animal, you
wouldn't wonder
whether there was or wasn't
a smallest number of neurons.
We may not know what it is.
But there's surely a
smallest number of neurons
because neurons are
nonnegative integers.
And finally, if I ask you what
was the smallest number of US
coins that could
make $1.17, again, we
don't have to worry
about existence
because the well ordering
principle knocks that
off immediately.
Now for the remainder
of this talk,
I'm going to be talking about
the nonnegative integers
always, unless I
explicitly say otherwise.
So I'm just going to
is the word number
to mean nonnegative integer.
There's a standard
mathematical symbol
that we use to denote
the nonnegative integers.
It's that letter N at
the top of the slide
with a with a
diagonal double bar.
These are sometimes called
the natural numbers.
But I've never been able
to understand or figure out
whether 0 is natural or not.
So we don't use that phrase.
Zero is included in N,
the nonnegative integers.
And that's what we call
them in this class.
Now, I want to point
out that we've actually
used the well ordering
principle already
without maybe not
noticing it, even
in the proof that the square
root of 2 was not rational.
That proof began by saying,
suppose the square root of 2
was rational, that is, it was a
quotient of integers m over n.
And the remark was that you
can always express a fraction
like that in lowest terms.
More precisely, you can always
find positive numbers m and n
without common factors, such
that the square root of 2
equals m over n.
If there's any fraction equal
to the square root of 2,
then there is a lowest
terms fraction m
over n with no common factors.
So now we can use well
ordering to come up
with a simple, and hopefully
very clear and convincing,
argument for why
every fraction can
be expressed in lowest terms.
In particular, let's
look at numbers m and n
such that the square root
of 2 is equal to m over n--
that fraction.
And let's just choose the
smallest numerator that works.
Find the smallest numerator
m, such that squared of 2
is equal to m over n.
Well, I claim that
that fraction, which
uses the smallest
possible numerator,
has got to be in lowest
terms because suppose
that m and n had a common
factor c that was greater
than 1-- a real common factor.
Then you could replace
m over n by m over c,
the numerator is a
smaller numerator that's
still an integer, and n over c.
The denominator is
still an integer.
And we have a numerator
that's smaller than m
contradicting the way that we
chose m in the first place.
And this contradiction,
of course,
implies that m and n
have no common factors.
And therefore, as claimed,
m over n is in lowest terms.
And of course, the
way I formulated
this was for our application
of the fraction that was
equal to the square root of 2.
But this proof actually shows
that any rational number,
any fraction, can be
expressed in lowest terms.